Валерій, працівник заводу з виготовлення тротуарної плитки, з гордістю демонструє,
як його витвір розбити неможливо - на відміну від звичайної бетонної плитки.
Ця ж не розлітається? Сильніше?
Складники такої міцної плитки несподівані: 70% річкового піску і 30% - пластику.
Його отримали з розплавленого поліетилену - пакетів та кульків.
Такий практичний спосіб утилізації відходів вигадали в Іллінецькій ОТГ, що на Вінниччині.
Тут не просто запровадили сортування сміття, але й почали розумно переробляти відходи.
Вважиться на вагах і потім під пресом хвилин 30 постоїть.
Якість? Сокира від неї відскакує, не розбивається, не плавиться на сонці, запаху немає.
Важко уявити, що ще кілька років тому на території заводу було… сміттєзвалище,
куди з 80-тих років звозили відходи з понад 30-ти сіл Вінниччини.
Коли полігон став переповненим, селяни почали створювати стихійні звалища довкола.
За вирішення сміттєвої кризи взялися чотири роки тому, як тільки-но створили Іллінецька ОТГ.
Спершу в місті Іллінці та прилеглих селах встановили - чи не першими у Вінницькій області -
баки для роздільного сортування сміття. Пластик та скло накопичували
та відправляли великим заготівельникам. Згодом ОТГ зробила наступний крок:
придбала сміттєсортувальний комплекс. У спеціальному барабані через сито органіка
відділяється від твердих побутових відходів, які одразу ж, на сортувальному столі,
перебирають працівники заводу.
Я перебираю плівку і картон…
Через рік роботи комплексу з'ясували, що частка поліетилену від пакетів і
кульків складає понад чверть усіх відходів. І її, на відміну від твердого пластику, важко реалізувати,
тож на заводі вирішили переробляти її самостійно.
Технологію запозичили з вінницького підприємства, яке з полімерів виготовляє  каналізаційні люки.
Якби не сніг, можна було б побачити, як виглядають викладені нею пішохідні доріжки в центрі міста.
Екологічні ініціативи Іллінецька громада фінансує частково з власного бюджету,
частково - за допомогою обласного екологічного фонду. Схожою формулою співфінансування
можуть скористатися громади й у інших областях. Це дозволить їм теж поступово
вирішувати сміттєву проблему, вважають депутати екологічного комітету Верховної Ради.
У  нас зараз сформовані самодостатні ОТГ, які можуть уже, і ми думаємо над цією програмою,
робити план управління відходами і затверджувати його. І закладати, якщо це потрібно,
підприємства, які будуть сортувати, відсортовувати те, що не можна переробити,
спалювальні установки встановлювати, щоб вони на своїх територіях могли це робити.
На практиці ж лише поодинокі громади беруться за проблему сміття.
Для більшості  - тема екології та поводження з відходами вирішується за залишковим принципом.
Так відбувається як через невеликі бюджети ОТГ, так і через низьку культуру
поводження з відходами, кажуть в Асоціації ОТГ. Аби це змінити, тут проводять вебінари
та тренінги для голів ОТГ, на яких розповідають про успішні досвіди інших громад.
Жашківська громада, село Бузівка, презентувала, як запровадили розібраний збір сміття,
як проводити просвітницьку роботу для учнів в школах, для населення,
зробили магнітики на холодильники, людям донесли, де ці пункти збору,
в який колір контейнера що викидати.
І таким чином у себе в сільській місцевості впровадили роздільний збір сміття.
За спостереженням Асоціації, у багатьох громад немає навіть сміттєвоза,
аби централізовано доставляти сміття на полігони. А досягненням уже вважається
встановлення в селі бодай одного баку для вивозу сміття. Ті ж ОТГ, які вже почали сортувати відходи,
зіштовхуються з проблемою економічної нерентабельності накопичення сировини.
Адже вартість вторсировини не окуповує витрати на її зберігання і транспортування.
Непросто заключати й договори на вивезення сміття із селянами.
З цією проблемою зіштовхнулися і в зразковій Іллінецькій громаді.
Це при тому, що ця послуга тут коштує лише 15 гривень на місяць з людини.
Люди не відмовляються, просто дуже тяжко укласти договір. Вони, можливо, і хочуть,
але не в всіх фінансово виходить.  Зараз укладено 60-70% на вивіз сміття.
Я вважаю, що це нормально - небагато і не мало. Але в подальшому цей показник зросте.
Укладають, бо бачать, що ми добре робимо свою роботу.
Завдяки власному виробництву плитки громада економить кошти на облаштування тротуарів
і вкладає їх в озеленення міста. Плитку не продають - спершу хочуть покрити потреби 33-ох сіл,
які входять до Іллінецької ОТГ. Переваги розумного ставлення до відходів
місцеві вже побачили наочно і не уявляють, як можна жити інакше.
Дуже-дуже гарно стало з комунгоспом, що приїхав і забрав. І чистенько стало, і дуже гарно. Краса.
Сортуємо, звичайно: пляшки, поліетилен і скло окремо.
Пляшки, скло, звісно, окремо, бо стоять баки спеціально для пластику. Звичайно, сортуємо.
Органічне окремо. І це дуже добре для нас, бо все переробляється.
З пластику роблять плитку для наших Іллінців. Люди приїжджають до нас,
дивляться з інших ОТГ і переймають досвід.
Лише 20% сміття Іллінецька ОТГ захороняє на полігоні. У планах громади -
досягти 100-відсоткової утилізації та стати першою безсміттєвою громадою України.
Тож, у планах будівництво сміттєспалювального заводу та встановлення на ньому
дорогих очисних фільтрів. Аби привабити відвідувачів і показати їм,
що сміттєпереробний комплекс безпечний для людей і довкілля, тут навіть відкрили мінізвіринець
- з дикими кабанами, кроликами, косулями. А на місці стихійних звалищ,
де вітер ганяв пластик і літали ворони, нині росте яблуневий сад.